so last night was really crappy for
Republicans in Virginia we will give you
the entire analysis from beginning to
end without myth or bias plus President
Trump heads to South Korea and we will
look at a little bit of bibble talk I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so as you can tell I was crying so hard
last night that the snot has not yet
stopped flowing I have a horrible cold
that my children keep giving me one of
the wonderful things about children is
that they are delightful one of the
horrible things that they constantly get
you sick there's giant balls of germs in
any case we will soldier through with
the bravery of Spartan warriors but
before we get to any of what happened in
Virginia last night first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
tracker so we have a routine in my house
it goes like this it's time to leave I
need my wallet I need my keys I need my
phone I have none of these things so we
spend the next three hours looking for
all of those things by which time it's
time to put my children to bed and then
we don't have to leave the house at all
it's not as delightful as it sounds it
would be really nice if I knew where all
of those things were fortunately I now
have trackers so this has now been
reduced
what tracker does is the coin size
device you can stick it on your keychain
you can stick it in your wallet and it
allows you to find all of these things
around the house simply with the push of
a button so if you have your keys you
hit the button and it hooks right up to
your phone for example you lost your
phone and you even turn your ringer off
on your phone it overrides the the ring
off on your phone and now your phone
will actually ring so you can find your
phone even if it's turned off in terms
of the in terms of the ringer the same
thing is true of your keys from your
phone you can locate your keys or your
wallet that's what tracker is for and
the tracker pixel means that you don't
have to worry about losing things ever
again
again tracker makes a great gift
especially during the holiday season you
have 20% off your order when you go to
the tracker comm slash men again that's
the tracker dot-com slash pen for 20%
off the tracker dot-com / pen
never lose your phone your keys your
wallet ever again it makes your life
super simple that's why I use the
tracker comm and use that / Bendi a 20%
off and let them know that we set you ok
so last night Republicans got their
asses kicked in Virginia and that really
is not an overstatement
I had gillespie ends up losing my almost
10 points in Virginia going into the
election it was assumed that Gillespie
was gaining
everyone on Morning Joe you know your
great political analyst on Morning Joe
had suggested that Gillespie was
definitely going to win universally I
was asked by Andrew Clavin who I thought
was going to win I informed him I no
longer bet on elections after 2016 but
if I had a lien I would have been
leaning toward north on the Democrat in
in Virginia it wasn't just northern
winning it was northern winning big and
it wasn't just northern winning it was
Democrats down the ballot winning in
enormous numbers so Republicans going
into this particular election cycle and
I believe 66 seats in the state
legislature they finished last night
with 47 so they just got shellacked all
the way across the board and it wasn't
just Republicans in Virginia Democrats
picked up a couple of seats in Georgia
excuse me in the state legislature there
and the state legislature those seats
were so read the Democrats had not run
in those districts for the last election
cycle they ran this time they ran this
time and they won okay not just that the
governorship of New Jersey is lostcape
that you can predict it but the
Washington state legislature turns from
Republican to Democrat with the loss of
a legislative seat in Washington what
this means that Democrats are
outperforming the polls it means the
Democrats are showing up in bigger
numbers than Republicans were assuming
that they were going to and they're a
bunch of Democrats including radical
Democrats elected across Virginia last
night including the first transgender
delegate to the Virginia House of
Burgesses in the history of Virginia
obviously as the second transgender
delegate I believe ever to any to any
legislative body I think the first one
was was in 1992 is actually Republican
in in in Atlanta but in any case the
Democrats are celebrating this as some
sort of massive victory so we're going
to analyze this from a couple different
angles because there are a couple of
different narratives that are now taking
effect one is that this was just
inevitable
okay Virginia has been moving blue
particularly in Northern Virginia near
Washington DC everyone who was in
Washington DC working commutes out to
Alexandria and that's where they live
they all live in Alexandria in the in
the northern portion of the state and
that part is becoming more blue and more
populous and so this was just the
natural after effect of all of that and
there is something to this so this is a
map tweeted out by someone named Jamie
Dupree
Jimmy Dupree tweets out a map showing on
the bottom you can see the 2016 Clinton
Trump map right at Hillary won the state
by about five percentage points four
15:45 northern one the state by 5445 and
then you see the top map there the top
map is last night and you do see a
couple of big transition points okay the
first one you see is you look at the
bottom right-hand corner facing it
anyway of the map what you will see is
Virginia Beach right Virginia Beach was
red in 2016 now it is blue so Trump had
one that he lost it last night you also
see some of the blue areas becoming
bluer the red area is becoming lighter
shades of red so the entire state is
moving toward the left and it has been
for quite a while the 2016 map between
2013 and 2017 Virginia moves steadily
Democratic certainly since 2009 when Bob
McDonnell won by 17 points in the
gubernatorial race the state has moved
dramatically to the left it's also
important to mention that the
gubernatorial loss is not unprecedented
so the Trump is the fifth president in a
row to have his party lose both the
Virginia and the New Jersey
gubernatorial races in his first year in
office so he lost this year to North
Amanda Murphy and in New Jersey in 2009
MacDonald won and Christie won they were
both Republicans after Obama was elected
in 2001 Warner and McGreevy won in the
various states Republicans have not been
winning in Virginia for quite a while
McDonald is the only major victory in
Virginia but the state legislature has
been heavily red for quite a while it no
longer is okay so this is sort of the
extent of the analysis that a lot of
people who are pro Trump wanna do I
think sends what the analysis is the
state was already moving red what are
you whining about
Mike Trump lost the state by 5 so last
night gillaspie lost by 9 so Trump is
better than Gillespie so what's the big
deal right the state was already moving
in the wrong direction what are you
wanting about I think this is far too
simplistic because again off your
elections are bad for presidents they
are bad for the president of the the
incumbent party and that means that
Republicans are likely to be in trouble
in the house so the average loss in
House elections for the last 50 60 years
in off your elections has been around 25
seats Republicans have a 23 seat
majority in the House of Representatives
right now so if just the average swing
happens Republicans lose the House of
Representatives but we were told that
Trump was gonna win like no other
winning winning winning winning right so
that's a bit of an excuse but let's take
it at face value
and the question isn't what the
Republicans lose 22 seats the question
is whether Republicans lose 30 or 35
seats when we saw last night in Virginia
was a wave and that's a combination of
factors in my opinion that is yes places
like Virginia moving to the left but
more importantly it is a very unpopular
president remember Trump is unpopular
right now and he has three to four
percent economic growth every quarter if
the bottom falls out on the economy at
any point here that dudes gonna be in
the 20s faster than you can say anything
I mean this is the they could really
fall apart very quickly here unpopular
president off your election motivated
Democratic base the Democratic base is
motivated for two reasons one they
despise president Trump and without
Trump on the ballot a bunch of
Republicans didn't show up and two
Republicans also didn't show up because
Hillary Clinton wasn't on the ballot the
big difference between 2016 and 2017 is
not Trump on the ballot it's Hillary
Clinton not being on the ballot Hillary
Clinton not being on the ballot was a
major boon to Democrats there's a solid
case to be made that Democrats - Hillary
is greater than GOP plus Trump then in
other words the Democrats gained more by
not having Hillary on the ticket than
the Republicans gained by having Trump
around especially in Northern Virginia
where the Republicans just got wiped out
in Loudoun County right which is the DC
exurbs in 2014 I don't know SP who ran
for Senate in 2014 in Virginia also ran
for governor last night in Virginia in
2014 Gillespie won Loudoun County by 456
votes yesterday he lost it by 24
thousand votes 24 thousand votes that is
a massive shift and one of the reasons
for that shift is that suburban people
did not like president Trump their exit
polls yesterday showing from ABC News
that the people who said they voted
because of the president voted two to
one against Gillespie so there was a big
move against Trump here and that does
have an effect so an unpopular president
a candidate who's trying to run a
trumpian campaign when he's not really a
trumpian the fact that the Democrats are
are jazzed up about 2018 in a way
Republicans are not Republicans haven't
done anything with the legislative power
they have also it is quite possible and
this is the contention that I have been
making for literally a year since the
election literally one year because
today is that after the election the the
case that I have been making is that
Hillary Clinton won the election for
President Trump that hope that President
Trump did not actually win the election
Hillary Clinton lost the election no one
showed up to vote for her
and the evidence that I base this on is
that in Wisconsin what you see is an
actual is an actual loss of votes from
2012 to 2016 Mitt Romney won more votes
in 2012 than them Donald Trump won in
2016 in Wisconsin Trump won the state
Romney lost the state that's cuz people
showed up to vote for Obama who didn't
show up to vote for Clinton in 2004
george w bush won more votes in Michigan
than Donald Trump did in 2016
Trump wins the state Bush loses the
state why because people showed up to
vote for John Kerry who didn't show up
to vote for Hillary Clinton it's that
simple
well that's what you're seeing now
Democrats did not vote in the last
election cycle for two reasons one they
thought Hillary was gonna win in a walk
that's what the polls were saying the
New York Times was saying a 99% chance
that Hillary Clinton was going to be
President of the United States on the
morning of the election cycle right this
is they're saying all the way up until
the evening a 99 percent chance that she
was going to be the next president of
the United States and so people didn't
Trump to folks they figured she's gonna
win anyway what does it matter if I go
to shop to vote and to Hillary's most
off-putting candidate in the history of
American politics no one wanted to get
out and vote for her she's not on the
ballot anymore you know who's still on
the ballot Trump so now you get what the
Democrats thought it was gonna be
there's a big argument in 2016 is this
election about Trump or is it about
Hillary right gotta pick one is about
Trump or Hillary I said the entire
election cycle was about Hillary Clinton
Hillary was bouncing around the pole she
was going everywhere from 50 to 40 where
was she gonna end up that was the big
question Trump was very steady between
40 and 45 always right and he was
usually between 43 and 45 and I figured
okay 45 percent is not enough to win
turns out it is but bottom line is that
now you get the referendum up with the
referendum on Trump the referendum on
Hillary's that everyone thought she was
terrible
the referendum on Trump now that no one
else is on the ballot is that Trump is
not popular okay and that does have a
pretty major impact now what the
Democrats are doing is they're trying to
translate this over into a a national
campaign they're basically running
Hillary ISM without Hillary one of the
things that's fascinating is that a lot
of people were saying last night what
you saw was trumpism without Trump I'm
gonna explain why that's not true in a
second and why what you're actually
seeing right now is Hillary ISM without
Hillary in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over the
u.s. concealed-carry Association so
you've heard me talking about the u.s.
CCA a lot lately and now
they are looking to take your home
defense and concealed-carry confidence
to the next level by inviting you to
their free live training event very cool
Tuesday at the fourteenth all about what
to do if you are forced to defend
yourself in your home you'll get to ask
questions live as personal defense
experts reveal what you can and can't
when you can and cannot use deadly force
in your home what happens after you
shoot you will be arrested no matter
what training drills to keep your skills
sharp and much more be confident your
ability to protect your family in your
home go to concealed-carry live.com
right now to secure your spot that's
concealed-carry live.com right now to
secure your spot and you'll get three
chances to win a Glock 19
just for registering again they're
giving away three Glocks live during the
training obviously you have to pass
whatever check you have to pass go to
concealed-carry live.com now to get your
three chances to win concealed carry
live.com right now to get your three
chances to win spots are filling up fast
concealed-carry live.com check it out
pretty awesome thing you get to ask a
live questions to actual experts on
these subjects okay so there's a lot of
talk last night about Trump and we'll
get to Trump in just a second but what
we actually saw was Hillary ISM on the
ballot without Hillary so you had a
bunch of candidates who ran campaigns
very similar to Hillary Clinton's but
they weren't as nasty and and
off-putting as Hillary Clinton Ralph
Northam ran a pretty nasty low down
campaign accusing ed gillespie of racism
and bigotry
he had a Latino victory caucus put out
that ad that I showed you I what I think
is the worst ad in American political
history showing a Gillespie truck trying
to run down minority children and then
nor them had the gall to go out there
and say that Virginia rejected hatred
and bigotry here's Ralph Northam the new
governor of the state of Virginia today
Virginians have answered and have spoken
Virginia has told us to end the divisive
mist that weed will not condone hatred
and bigotry and to end the politics that
have torn this country apart I want to
let you know
that in Virginia it's gonna take a
doctor to heal our differences he of
course is a doctor so that means that
okay so in any case this is sure
nonsense the idea that they rejected
hatred and bigotry that if Ed Gillespie
had won then people in Confederate flag
trucks were gonna be running down
children and then they say that they're
uniting then they say are uniting he's
runnin Hillary's campaign right this is
what Hillary said about deplorable
he's running Hillary's campaign in an
off-year election and he's doing it
without Hillary's face and this makes a
big difference it demonstrates how
unpopular Hillary Clinton was the same
thing was happening over in New Jersey
the the guy named Phil Murphy is the new
governor over in New Jersey replacing
Chris Christie when Christie's turb is
up and he's doing the same thing we have
a new unity right here again this is
Hillary ISM without Hillary tonight we
declare the days of division are over we
will move forward together this is
exactly who we are New Jersey we have
each other's backs
to believe in each of us is to believe
in all of us
okay so again they're gonna do the whole
unity routine running the Hillary
campaign without Hillary Clinton and
they can win on that okay it's not the
Republicans agenda was was radically you
know greenlit over the past eight years
it was that they're running against
Barack Obama well now Democrats get to
run against Donald Trump and they get to
do so without Hillary Clinton's face at
the head of their ticket that makes a
very very large difference so one of the
questions that's being asked is
basically did Gillespie fight hard
enough so one of the so in defense of
Trump you know what I'm saying here is
that Trump's unpopularity definitely
hurts people down ballot that it drives
Democrats to the polls in a way it
doesn't drive Republicans to the polls
that Trump's approval rating is
historically awful again that ABC News
exit polling showed quote voters by a
two-to-one margin said they were casting
their ballots to show opposition to
Trump rather than support for him in New
Jersey that margin was three to one
people may thrill to Trump's cultural
warfare on the right but it also drives
a bunch of people on the left to the
polls yeah so this is the case that I'm
making but some of this has to do with
Trump not all of it has to do with Trump
but some of it does a lot of people on
the on the Trump side are saying no no
no no no the reason that Gillespie lost
is because he wasn't Trumpkin enough
right is it this is always if your
theory is that Trump is God King Emperor
then everything bad that happens there
new hypothesis that's been created okay
the hypothesis that's been created is
that when someone wins it's because they
were warm to trump and when someone
loses it's because they weren't warm
enough to Trump it's never about the
reality cuz Gillespie basically ran a
very trumpian campaign he didn't openly
campaign with Trump if he had openly
campaigned with Trump he would have lost
worse in the DC exurbs up in northern in
Northern Virginia
he won exactly the same percentage that
Trump won in the state the difference is
the Democrats showed up to vote for
Democrats this time and so the last be
one forty five percent so did Trump
bottom line is Gillespie ends up losing
by ten Trump ends up losing by five
that's because all the Democrats showed
up to vote in fact by polls forty one
percent of people who voted yesterday in
Virginia were Democrats only thirty one
percent said they were Republicans so
what the trumpian people have been
saying is well Gillespie lost because he
didn't fight hard enough if he'd only
had a little more Trump in him than he
would have won and to support this they
say look look at the Democrats they were
calling him a racist and a bigot and
Gillespie didn't fight back hard enough
on that they points people like Terry
McAuliffe the the current governor of
the state of Virginia who definitely
wants to run for president
here's McAuliffe ripping into Gillespie
I'm predicting we're gonna win all three
statewide Zab unch of House of Delegates
it's been a great race Ralph Northam is
gonna be the next governor everybody is
happy in the state as you just say we're
a safe state a record amount of economic
investment and Ed Gillespie has run
really a racist bigoted campaign
horrible ads Donald Trump today is now
doing robo calls Donald Trump's at 31%
in Virginia we're gonna reject that and
we are gonna move forward as a
Commonwealth and Ralph is gonna be the
next governor McAuliffe you ran a racist
bigoted campaign well he's talking about
his Gillespie around an ad saying that
Ralph Northam backed sanctuary cities
and you link that to ms-13 okay that's
not a racist ad that's a typical
political ad Gillespie well when people
say Gillespie is a milquetoast that he's
an establishment guy what they really
mean is that he's not trumpian in the
way that he fights back I would like him
to be a bit more trumpian in the way
that he fights back by the way here's
Gillespie for example saying last night
that Ralph Northam is a good man yeah a
good man who called him a racist and a
bigot
as I said throughout the course of this
campaign governor elect Northam is a
good man and I appreciate his service to
our country and our Commonwealth and I
wish him nothing but the best success as
our 73
governor and told him that if I could be
helpful to him in making our
Commonwealth better that I would be
happy to do anything I could in that
regard there are a lot of people who are
saying well you know this sort of
conciliatory show by Gillespie
demonstrates why he lost I think there's
something to that
I think Gillespie should fight back
harder it's one of the things I always
appreciated about President Trump even
when I wasn't supporting him you know
the fact is that I think Trump does
fight back I think he fights back on
things that are stupid and I think he
fights back on things that are not
stupid Gillespie did not fight back
nearly as hard as he should have on
things like that Latino victory ad but
is that why Gillespie lost it doesn't
explain why Republicans got shellacked
down ballot it doesn't explain why they
lost two seats in Georgia it doesn't
explain why they lost the Washington
State Senate it doesn't explain why the
state of Maine just voted to increase
Medicare doesn't explain any of those
things so I don't quite buy that but
this is going to be the hypothesis of
people defending Trump is that the
reason that Gillespie lawsuit because he
didn't hug Trump hard enough and this is
actually a crucial distinction question
should Republican candidates hug Trump
really hard or should they try and
distance themselves or should they try
to like straddle belt line I think the
only thing they can do is try to
straddle blonds because if you hug Trump
really hard you are driving Democrats to
the polls if you do not hug Trump really
hard then Trump could actually crap all
over you which as you will see Trump did
too Gillespie or the Trump base could
decide that they are going to turn on
you because you are not supportive
enough of Trump this is the problem with
cults of personality is that if you
support from so much that you're willing
to not go out and vote for a typical
Republican because they weren't nice to
Trump then you are undercutting Trump's
own ability to govern it's just
foolishness but that means that a lot of
Republicans are caught between a rock
and a hard place they don't want to hug
Trump because if they hug Trump they
lose suburban soccer moms and if they
don't hug Trump and Trump craps all over
them and the base and the base deserts
them it is a serious problem Laura
Ingraham last night she was suggesting
what really should have happened here is
Gillespie should have just hugged Trump
really hard and this is gonna be the the
going line that that more you're gonna
see more and more I'm gonna discuss
trumpism in just a second but first
Trump personally that the the typical
media line is because the entire
politics now revolves around Trump
people like Laura Ingraham and even
Chris Matthews they're saying
Gillespie's big mistake is that he he
didn't fight he didn't hug from hard
enough here's it here's Ingram those big
suburban counties around Washington DC
just right over there went even more for
Northam than they did for Hillary which
I think what does that tell you that
tells you a populous conservative like
Trump who has a strong personality and a
strong message did do better he didn't
spend a lot of time campaigning in
Virginia Donald Trump and Ed Gillespie
tried to do this dance that yeah I'm not
gonna campaign with Trump at he'll tweet
form you know do a last-minute robo call
I think in the end that came off as
desperate okay so he's she's saying that
it was too little too late right that
yeah he was trying to embrace Trump yeah
he was trying to be more like Trump but
it was too desperate
ready wasn't authentic it didn't really
come off that was really the big problem
here the reason the Donald Trump did
better than Gillespie in the northern
suburbs is because Hillary Clinton was
on the ballot it's about Hillary not
about Trump it's so funny whenever it
comes to Hillary being a tool to be used
there are a lot of hosts who will use
Hillary as a tool when they wish to
misdirect from Trump okay this is a case
where they are using Trump to misdirect
from Hillary the reality is Democrats
did not show up because of Hillary end
of story
okay Chris Matthews though saying the
same thing the West B pretended to be a
trump stern he couldn't pull it off he
just wasn't authentic enough got in the
mind come in at a show come on in your
dev ed gillespie who's this guy ah go I
think Democrats should have a morale
boost like they've never had tonight but
they have to say now we got to get out
there and sell something we got to sell
some whether it's a better health care
program a jobs program or something I
think they got to be part that's just me
talking I think it's just a good night
for the Democrats I don't want to take
any of the joy out of it they beat the
hell out of this guy who pretended to be
a Trumpster ed gillespie is a Washington
lobbyist
he's weighed at knee deep or head deep
in the swamp he's part of the problem
Trump ran against
okay so now this is the typical my math
used to tend to similar populist again
Ingram and in Matthews both banging the
case but if that if Gillespie had been
more like Trump than maybe he would have
won no no okay that's just the data do
not show this so what's the next line of
defense for for a lot of the people who
are advocates of Trump we want to
suggest that what happened in Virginia
has nothing to do with Trump the next
line of defense the first line of
defense was again there are three lines
of defense Winer defense number one was
Virginia was already moving to the left
true true
to only goes so far but true second line
of defense Gillespie if you'd been more
like Trump he would have done better
very very dubious and final line of
defense is that trumpism requires Trump
right this is that he wasn't trumpet
enough right the Gillespie it wasn't
just the Trump did that Gillespie didn't
embrace Trump he's in embrace trumpism
he didn't embrace the nationalist
populist movement right this is the line
the Steve Bannon is using now is he
saying that like the way that they ran
their headline over Breitbart last night
is they said that the swamp thing
Gillespie was defeated five seconds ago
Annan was trying to campaign for
Gillespie saying that he was attempting
to drain the swamp so they're flipping
on that one as well so I want to talk a
little bit about about whether trumpism
even exists in just a second because you
have advocates for Trump as was saying
well that was the problem
Gillespie just wasn't trumpet enough
nothing did embrace Trump personally but
also he wasn't populist enough and then
he had people on the Left saying well
this shows that trumpism has failed and
I'm gonna offer a third hypothesis
trumpism does not exist something I've
been saying now for well over a year
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so if
you are looking to prepare for an
emergency you look at their a lot of
natural disasters on the news there we
have a lot of enemies foreign and
domestic
you know people who are attempting to to
create chaos you may be stuck in a
situation where you can't get to the
grocery right you're you're at home some
sort of natural disaster has taken place
the grocery is cleaned out or you just
can't get there and the government can't
help you this is why you need an
emergency food supply in your home get a
102 serving survival food kit for just
99 bucks from my Patriot supply they
help you prepare for the next emergency
breakfasts lunches at dinners it is
shipped to your home for free order a
kit for yourself call eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen again
that's eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or go online to
prepare with been calm again is prepared
with been calm the emergency food lasts
up to 25 years in storage eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
prepare with Ben's outcome folks around
the office say it tastes like home
cooking more importantly you and your
family are gonna be safe and protected
you're gonna stick it in a closet forget
about it until disaster strikes and then
you were prepared because you were smart
prepare with Ben calm eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen again
prepare with Ben calm so in so again
there were the two to reiterate the
three hypotheses right one was
Virginia's moving left true to was this
doesn't have to do with with Trump it's
because Gillespie didn't embrace Trump
hard enough I think that's wrong this is
what Trump was hanging himself by the
way here's Trump's tweet on this last
night
Trump tweeted this is a danger for
Republicans when you tweeted right Harry
tweeted ed gillespie worked hard but did
not embrace me or what I stand for
don't forget Republicans won four out of
four House seats and with the economy
doing record numbers who will continue
to win even bigger than before
here is the problem what you can see
from Trump is that Trump now has an
interest in not associating himself with
Republicans because if they lose he
loses so instead what he's gonna do is
crap all over Republicans and then
suggest that if they just embrace him
harder everything would have been fine
he's gonna play into this false
unfalsifiable hypothesis that every
Trump way everyone is a trump Lin and
every loss is because you didn't embrace
from pardon of Salle's hypothesis number
two finally hypothesis number three is
about trumpism Trumpets will say well
Gillespie didn't just not embrace Trump
he didn't embrace trumpism he shouldn't
be more populist are you sure that
that's the line that he should have used
is that he should have he should have
just even if he wasn't gonna brace Trump
he had to he had to embrace Trump's
program there are a couple problems miss
one Trump doesn't have a program to the
people who are saying this are wildly
inconsistent as to what trumpism
constitutes Steve ban and most
prominently has been trying to pose
himself as I have said for months now as
the head of a trumpet Smoove meant
without Trump that he will defend
trumpism against Trump even that's his
job well trumpism doesn't exist in the
absence of Trump Gillespie tried to do
at rumpus campaign it failed so I think
Jake Tapper on CNN goes too far he says
this was a rejection of trumpism I don't
think that's exactly correct and I'll
explain why CNN projecting the Ralph
Northam the Democratic lieutenant
governor will win and it has to be seen
to a degree I think as a rejection of
President Trump who is the strongest
prevailing political figure in the
country if you look at who turned out
according to the exit polls and how
often people who supported Trump voted
for Gillespie and how many how often
people who oppose Trump voted for
Northam that is a very strong sign of a
rejection of Trump okay so the idea
again that trumpism is being overthrown
this suggests that Trump is amiss think
trumpism is not a thing there's a
backlash to Trump personally but I'm not
sure that trumpism is an actual program
if Republicans want to win they're gonna
have to ask President Trump to do better
I don't know why this is controversial
in any way it's not a rip on President
Trump to suggest he needs to do better
britt hume who's been very supportive of
president
comes out last night he says look it's
obvious from some popularity heard
Gillespie clearly Trump stirs passions
and the people who are for a more
passionate and the people who are
against him are passionate in the state
of Virginia remember he lost Virginia
it's the only southern state he lost
really so right you know you think about
that this is not the Virginia really
isn't Trump country and then aroused
electorate in Virginia is gonna be bad
news for Republican running any age of
Trump okay what this says that in 2018
Republicans have some very solid
systemic disadvantages they've a serious
problem in 2018 Democrats are going to
be energized they're going to show up
the average swing is going to be toward
the out party plus Trump is the most
energizing candidate Democrats have
faced ever ever okay so that means that
they are going to show up in massive
numbers it could be a wipeout for
Republicans so Republicans had better
get on their horse and start recruiting
some people between 2000 and 2004 George
W Bush picked up some 10 to 12 million
American voters he lost the popular vote
by 500,000 he then picked up 10 to 12
million voters and he only won the
election by a couple of million votes
right who is Donald Trump picking up
right now so well I think what this
election more than anything else should
show in Virginia is that the entire
system of thought that we just keep
doubling down on the base the base the
base the base the base he hasn't lost
his base yet he's you know as long as
you doesn't lose his base he's fine
inaccurate he can keep his base if the
base doesn't grow Trump's gonna lose in
2020 and Republicans are getting it
slaughtered in 2018 the base is not big
enough his base is 35 to 38 percent of
the population that's it
that is not enough to win a general
election and the Electoral College is
not gonna save you in congressional
elections it's not gonna save you this
time around in a in a popular election
when Hillary Clinton is not on the
ballot so as much as Republicans love to
hate Hillary Clinton the person they
should be most grateful to in 2016 is
not Donald Trump it is Hillary Clinton
they should be grateful to Hillary
Clinton for being such crappy candidate
if Democrats don't make the same mistake
in 2020 they made in 2016 and just to
point somebody wildly unpopular with the
American public they have an upper hand
and this is going to require Republicans
to do something being in power means
that you are more responsible there's
more risk and there's more reward the
risk is if you don't do anything people
are going to assume that you are just a
bag of hot wind and they're going to get
angry at you and if you do do something
you risk that you're gonna do the wrong
thing but it's also an opportunity it's
very high reward if you can shift
the ground if you can pass popular
legislation we can move people in your
column for a year Republicans have done
nothing in Congress again this is not on
Trump Republicans have done nothing in
Congress the backlash against the
Republican Party is strong because of
Trump because of Republicans because of
the system because Democrats are pissed
off and win in 2016
none of this bodes well for 2018 and if
Republicans take the wrong lessons here
if the lesson they take is Oh Trump is
fine everything's cool it's just
Virginia heed the warnings ok heed the
warnings because if you don't if
shellacking is coming and then I guess
well we'll play this game where we blame
never Trump and we blame they and we
blame you know people who weren't fully
Trumpy enough it's just if that's the
game that we're gonna play then we are
again not we are not involved in the
realm of reality I'm seeing I'm seeing
those talking points already this idea
that never Trump is to blame for what
happened in Virginia again there's no
evidence of that whatsoever the never
Trump movement is like three people it
was never a movement just cuz you didn't
vote for Trump didn't mean that you were
against Gillespie winning okay not
everybody's having McMullen I wanted
Advil SP to win I wanted Republicans to
retain power I think it's important that
they do it's really terrible what
happened last night in Virginia Trump
must do better he must do better
Republicans must do better I don't see
why any of this is even mildly
controversial okay
so meanwhile President Trump is over in
in South Korea and he's speaking about
North Korea at length he's talking about
China and he's talking about Russia and
here he was suggesting that it was time
to isolate North Korea and directly
posing a challenge to China and Russia
all responsible nations must join forces
to isolate the brutal regime of North
Korea to deny it and any form any form
of it you cannot support you cannot
supply you cannot accept we call on
every nation including China and Russia
to fully implement UN Security Council
resolutions downgrade diplomatic
relations with the regime and sever all
ties of Trade and Technology because
what Trump is doing here is the right
thing and this is the point okay when
your presidents of the United States you
have a capacity to win people over and
Trump is actually on the road to doing
that if he could just shut his mouth and
stick to script
or when Trump does that he's doing fine
a lot this is why a lot of people who
love Trump are angry when I comments on
what Trump comments on they say well why
are you engaging with that just look at
what he's doing right he's caught
regulations he's not spending as much
he's not growing the federal government
as fast on foreign policy is attempting
to to work with the military all of that
is true what makes him unpopular is not
this stuff it's the crap that he tweets
about out of gillespie right it's it's
it's the charlottesville comments that's
the stuff that makes him unpopular not
his actual policies here he was again
yesterday talking about North Korea in
what I think his language that most
Americans agree with this is a very
different administration than the United
States has had in the past today I hope
I speak not only for our countries but
for all civilized nations when I say to
the North do not underestimate us and do
not try us we will defend our common
security our shared prosperity and our
sacred Liberty we did not choose to draw
here on this financial okay so again all
of this is stuff that Trump can do just
fine but he's gonna need to cut out all
the ancillary stuff because that's what
makes him unpopular I don't want to beat
a dead horse here but if the takeaway
from Virginia is that we should all just
gladly go about our business and we were
making exactly the same mistake
Democrats made in 2009 when they assumed
that all the backlash to Obama was just
a bunch of talk remember
if Republicans just got shellacked in
Virginia with 3% growth for the last two
quarters with the economy doing well
with us relatively secure in foreign
policy what's gonna happen if something
goes wrong okay it could be a disaster
it's already a d-plus 11 congressional
generic ballot and what happens if they
win the house let's say that they win
the house they'll move to impeach Trump
presumably but if they don't move to
impeach Trump then then you could see
them sweeping if they move to impeach
Trump it'll get out the Trump base but
if they don't move to impeach Trump then
they could win back the Senate in 2022
the presidency in 2020 there's the
outside possibility they went back the
Senate this year or next year if they do
that you can kiss goodbye to the Supreme
Court because at that point they'll just
stymie whoever Trump appoints to the
Supreme Court
it's that the whole thing is it does
matter politics does matter elections do
matter what happened in Virginia last
night it's either gonna be seen as a
data points are part of a trend I think
it's part of a trend not just a data
point okay so before I go any further
and I want to read you a column from
there are times I think it's quite
ridiculous
in a second but before I go any further
I want to say thank you to one of our
new sponsors trippin comm so whenever I
travel with my wife and kids we have a
general problem staying in hotels the
reason is because we keep kosher so if
we go to someplace like Hawaii then
there is no kosher food there we have to
bring our food with us that means that
we have to get a place in the kitchen or
gonna have to get a place in the
multiple bedrooms right you don't want
it we have two kids who are under the
age of four you don't want them sleeping
in the same bedroom they wake each other
up and then they way they wake up us up
so if you have one bedroom like in a
hotel room you're totally screwed no one
gets any sleep at all well that's what
trippin comm is for you spend less time
planning your next trip more time
relaxing with trippin comm which is the
world's number one site for vacation
rentals this is you actually renting
like a condo for example you want a
kitchen you want multiple bedrooms with
tripping calm onesearch lets you filter
compare sort over 10 million available
properties on trusted sites like VRBO
TripAdvisor booking comm and more you
don't have to worry if you're getting
the best deal on that cabin that you're
going up to Big Bear for you will save
an average of 18% per night by booking
your vacation with trippin comm so if
you want to save time to end money while
booking the perfect vacation rental go
to trippin comm slash Shapiro trippin
comm slash Shapiro again check that out
at trippin comm slash appear that the
folks that we use and as I say every
time my wife and kids and I travel we
have to do a vacation rental tripping
comma slash apparel is the service that
we use go to slash Shapiro and let them
know that we sent you okay so there is
you know with with all of this said I
think the Democrats still have the
capacity to lose if they focus on
intersectionality if they continue to
focus on their social justice warrior
ring so you know there's there's this
idea this is how you got Trump that
continues to apply it's not that that
went away last night in Virginia so
Democrats have to be very careful the
campaign that Democrats ran in Virginia
was actually a moderate Hillary s
campaign not a full Bernie Sanders s
campaign and not a full-on
intersectional campaign northern did it
a little bit but he really campaigned
more as moderate than anything else he
look more like Joe Biden and then
anything else and what you are seeing is
what you're seeing from the left is them
tearing themselves open so while
Republicans are tearing themselves open
about Trump the left is tearing
themselves open about what is their
centering ideology and maybe Trump can
help bring them together around that I
mean Obama brought Republicans together
around anti Obama ISM and there are some
significant breaches in the Republican
platform for sure but if Democrats
continue to embrace the intersectional
theory that they have been embracing
thus far then that could lead to a trump
victory and to a Republican resurgence
his culture wars do Drive this culture
wars do make a difference with regard to
how people vote so you know Democrats
could still blow this I'll talk a little
bit more about how Democrats can can
blow this and I'll show you an instance
of Democrats seeking to blow it in just
a second but for all of that you're
gonna have to go and subscribe over at
se Lee Weyer com for $9.99 a month you
get a subscription to daily wire you get
the rest of my show live on video you
get the rest of Michael Knowles's show
live on video the rest of Andrew Klavan
show live on video and if you subscribe
you definitely want to be sure to take
it to tune in to watch our next episode
of the conversation happening next
Tuesday November 14th at 5 p.m. Eastern
2 p.m. Pacific featuring Michael Noel's
Michael's conversation will stream live
on The Daily wire website Facebook page
in YouTube it will be free for everyone
to watch but only if you are a
subscriber can you ask questions to
Michael Knowles and presumably he will
hold up a blank piece of paper and
answer subscribe today to ask Michael
questions and join the conversation
that's happening next to Tuesday if you
want the annual subscription get all of
these myriad glori's plus the greatest
in all beverage vessels this your very
own leftist tears hot or cold daily wire
branded tumblr you know the thing that
allows me to get through this show
without Hawking up my lung is this daily
wired tumblr I can do the same for you
so daily wired tumblr available to you
and get the annual subscription for 99
bucks a year which is a discount off the
monthly subscription or later go over
and subscribe at YouTube SoundCloud
iTunes leave us a review always helps
other people learn about the show and
find out about the show we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay time for some things I like and
some things that I hate so things that I
like I have been watching a stranger
things season two and normally I don't
see things I like on specific seasons of
shows but since this is such a big
phenomenon the the new stranger things
season is quite good I'm through eight
episodes I'm not through the last two
episodes yet and it is I have one left
it's nine episodes okay fine so I'm
close to the end of this thing and it is
it is very good I think it's better than
season one in a lot of ways I'm gonna
have to do a full season to recap at a
certain point on Facebook live where I
give my my criticisms I have particular
criticisms of one Nancy but we will
discuss that another time here is the
preview for stranger things season 2 we
gotta do this let's engage
[Music]
that's never good
you hear that rising noise that's always
bad in a preview so in any case it is
less I would say it's kind of less scary
in some ways than season one season one
I think is a scarier season because you
haven't seen any of these things before
this season is is a lot less scary but
it's also faster paced so it moves it
moves a lot faster the pacing and see in
episode one particularly is much better
and I do find it weird there are so many
people who are nostalgic for an era they
never lived through like I was born in
the year that this that this show takes
place takes place in 1984 and I'm sort
of nostalgic for it but that's because
the 80s and 90s are basically one long
continuation but there are a lot of
people who are nostalgic for the smart
kids you got seventeen year old kids who
love stranger things because they're
nostalgic for it
what that shows you is how much pop
culture is invested in our perception of
the past because what you're really
nostalgic for is not been 1984 well
you're really nostalgic for ZT right
well you're really nostalgic for it is
movies that were made about this period
because the movies were better in 1984
than they are today
it's just the reality of the situation
so you know it's it is fun to watch it
is it is well-written I'll be very
disappointed if in season 3 they start
with the social justice warrior ring
there are some rumors to that effect
that they're gonna make one of the kids
gay because they have to do that that
would be really irritating because come
on not everything has to be about the
sexuality of the characters or this kind
of nonsense but in any case the season
is is is well worth the watch so check
it out ok time for a quick thing that I
hate so I was talking about how the
Democrats can lose one of the ways the
Democrats can lose is if they suggest
that their brand is tied up with radical
left ISM right now Trump won by being
the default not Hillary right here's
more than that obviously but that's
probably why he was unpopular Hillary
was so terrible that Trump won by being
not Hillary right that was his entire
campaign was not Hillary right he would
say this Democrats now are and can win
if they say we're not Trump but instead
of doing that they feel the necessity to
go out and make fools of themselves to
demonstrate how passionate they are
about to cosmic ted Lieu who represents
a district over here in Los Angeles his
opponents again and dr. Kenneth Wright
whom I have endorsed for for Congress
Ted Lou said that he hears what happened
there was this moment of silence for the
victims in the Texas shooting
Ted Lou walked out of the moments of
silence okay and here's what he had to
say
but still a moment of silence some
people might say you even politicize
that I view ties doing my job to
highlight this issue because you don't
want Congress to just do moments of
silences every time a mass shooting
happens you want us to take action to
try prevent this shooting for happening
in the first place okay so the idea that
he's gonna walk out on a funeral
basically they didn't walk out on a
moment of silence in order to
demonstrate that he wants legislation on
gun control it's just absurd I tweeted
him yesterday and he didn't have any
very good responses on this I turned him
repeatedly saying so have you walked out
on funerals to go work at a soup kitchen
or do you like wait to finish the
funeral and then go to the soup kitchen
you know or why are you grandstanding
about these victims but you won't
grandstand about other victims are they
less valuable to you than these victims
or again this is all grandstanding the
more Democrats grandstand the more
they're gonna lose but if they keep
their mouth shut
and they just wait for the Republicans
to make mistakes that seems the way
politics works right now it's just wait
for your opponent to make a mistake and
then capitalize Democrats should be in
good shape if they do that but
fortunately for Republicans there's
always the question as to whether
Democrats can keep their mouth shut not
any other stuff okay time for a brief
Bible talk so I've been kind of going
through the stories almost a trans I'm
in the Bible I'm going through them sort
of in chronological order but giving a
little bit more in depth than I have
over the past couple of years so the
next story in the Bible that I think is
interesting after the Cain and Abel
story is the story of Noah so the
description of Noah in the Bible is that
he's a good man in his time right that
he walked with God and he was a good man
in his time so there's been a big debate
in Jewish Theological circles about what
it means to be a good man in your time
why does it say in his time right in
whose else time would he be a good man
so there are two ways to read this one
is that Noah was a good man even for his
time meaning he was living in a really
corrupt awful time and so the fact that
he was good in that time demonstrates
how great he was the other way to read
that is to say he was only good for that
time like if he lived today he wouldn't
be that great and a lot of that depends
on what you think of his tactic so
what's fascinating about Noah is that no
one doesn't spend a minute trying to
recruit other people to fix their ways
or build arks of their own or anything
right God says build an ark I'm
destroying the world Noah doesn't argue
with him no him says okay fine cool with
me
it starts building a giant Ark right
that's that's the idea here is that a
good thing or a bad thing
this mirrors a debate that happens in
religious communities all over the place
religious communities have to make a
very interesting decision the decision
is do you cloister yourself and your
children in an attempt to protect them
do you try to prevent them from seeing
news of the outside world do you try to
build a bubble for them so they're not
affected by the diseases of the outside
world or do you teach them to go out and
engage there is danger to engaging all
right if you engage you may lose some
people if you engage some people may
walk away from your faith and your
spirituality some people may be seduced
by the dark side so to speak or do you
build a bubble try to protect your kids
and I think the answer is supposed to be
some of both and it is time dependent or
you have to pick your spots so I don't
think the answer is always the same and
when I was a kid there's a kid living
next door and the kid was really trouble
I mean really troubled kid and my mom
had a certain perspective on this kid
she thought well Ben's a good kid the
kid next door is not a great kid if Ben
hangs out with this kid then Ben will
make the other kid better all right the
other kid will be better and my dad's
perspective was if Ben hangs out this
other kid this other kid could make been
worse now there this this all came to
the forefront it came as a combination I
when I was about maybe 3 or 4 years old
probably 3 and this other kid convinced
me to hide in the bushes a couple of
doors down from my parents house and not
to answer when my parents call me and so
my parents actually end up calling the
police because they didn't know where
I'd gone they thought maybe I'd been
kidnapped or something and when I came
out my parents said you're not allowed
to put that kid ever again there are
situations where you do have to protect
yourself from outside forces and then
there are situations where you have to
reach out right now is a situation where
conservatives have to reach out not just
because the country is on the brink but
also because they have the opportunity
to do so and this is sort of the case
I've been making about president Trump
and about Republicans don't hunker down
in your Trumpets bunker don't hunker
down in your conservative bunker go out
and win converts don't just yellow
people drunk just don't just yell Maggie
Maggie don't you talk about the base
figure out how you know when new people
over because if you don't do that the
Democrats are gonna drive out there
based at higher rates then we turn out
our base in 2018 2020 it's gonna be a
serious problem for Republicans okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with more
deconstruction i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]